here is a practical technique the first
thing you do you must know exactly what
you want in this world well you know
exactly what you want make as life like
a representation as possible suppose I
wanted a home but I had no money but I
still know what I want I without taking
anything into consideration I will make
as lifelike a representation of the home
that I would like with all the things in
it that I would want and then this night
as I would go to bed I would illustrate
a drowsy sleepy State I would imagine
that I'll actually in such a house that
will I just step off the bed I would
stand up on the floor of that house or I
to leave this room I would enter the
room that is adjacent to my imagined
room in that house and while I am
touching the furniture and feeling it to
be suddenly real and while I am moving
from one room to the other in my
imaginary house I will go sound asleep
in that state and I know that in a way I
could not consciously devise I would
realize my house I have seen it work
time and time again if I wanted
promotion in my business I would ask
myself what additional responsibilities
would be mine would I be given this
great promotion and then in my
imagination I will begin to see and
touch and do and act as I would outfully
see and touch and act were I in that
position Hey Stephen Carmichael and I
make these videos because in my first
business I struggled to stay afloat I
quit I'm a business partner and the
thing that kept me motivated kept me
going was studying the stories of famous
successful entrepreneurs and in their
stories it gave me the hope the drive
the ambition the thinking that maybe I
can do it too that extra bit of belief
and I still need their stories today and
I'm honored to share them with you here
as well so today let's learn how you can
visualize properly enjoy
rule number two is stop being defined by
your past with Joe dispenza meditation
the actual translation of the word
meditation means to become familiar with
so the first thing you have to do is you
have to become conscious of your
unconscious thoughts you got to notice
your automatic habits and behaviors and
you have to become aware of your
emotions that keep you anchored to the
past and if you can become so conscious
of the one unconscious states of mind
and body that they would never slip by
your conscious awareness again you're
becoming familiar with the old self so
you don't return then if you begin to
think about new ways of being being
defined by a vision
plan your behaviors review them in your
mind now if you keep doing that over and
over again nerve cells that fire
together wire together you begin to
become familiar with a new state of mind
at the same time if you can emotionally
cultivate your inspiration your joy Your
Enthusiasm ahead of the experience by
repeating that over and over again
cultivating that state it's going to
begin to become familiar to you so then
the process of change then requires
unlearning and relearning breaking the
habit of the old self Reinventing a new
self
tuning synaptic connections as we say in
neuroscience and sprouting new
connections unmemorizing emotions that
are stored in the body then here's the
key reconditioning the body to a new
mind into a new emotion it's literally
moving from your past to your future
it's losing your mind and creating a new
one and so then when you begin to
understand that in the in that process
it's going to feel a little bit
unfamiliar uncomfortable and if you can
relax into that instead of going back to
the past continuously invest in your
future sooner or later it'll begin to
become easier and easier and easier and
all of a sudden when you least expect it
something amazing is going to happen in
your life and when that event begins to
occur you're going to pay attention to
what you did inside of you now to
produce the effect outside of you and
that's called human empowerment and
there isn't a person in the world that's
excluded from this equation rule number
three is control your words and thoughts
of Louise Hay I believe that life is
really very simple what we give out we
get back and what we believe about
ourselves becomes true for us
our thinking creates our experiences
there is a law of thinking like
everything else like all of nature there
is a universal energy or law of mind or
subconscious mind whatever you want to
call it but to me it means the power
that is within me and around me
transforms my thoughts into experiences
you see I believe that we are all
responsible for everything in our lives
every thought we think and every word we
speak is creating our experiences our
future and it's almost as though every
time you think a thought or you speak a
word that Universal intelligence or
energy is listening or responding to
what you are thinking or believing or
saying without judgment or criticism
totally accepting us at our own value
whatever we choose to believe becomes
true for us also to make sure you're
actually taking action after watching
this video I designed a special free
worksheet just for this video the
worksheet will highlight all the Lessons
Learned in this video as well as pull
out our three favorite learnings and
quotes that will inspire you to actually
do something the worksheet will also
give you space to write down what your
key takeaways are and your specific plan
of action to make sure you're getting
results if you want the worksheet
designed specifically for this video
absolutely for free there's a link in
the description below go click on it and
start building the momentum in your life
and your business I'll see you there
rule number four is practice
manifestation with Eckhart Tolle the
greatest obstacle is probably
when meditation comes out of a sense of
lack or neediness so you feel you you
are deprived of something be it money or
uh
relationship or a living situation and
you feel there's a great lack in your
life and you desperately want this to
change
and so you perhaps
use manifestation in a way that is not
likely to work when for example you
use affirmations such as
uh I want a better job I want a job with
a good income and a life situation in a
nice place and I want this and I want
that
um by making these statements
you're actually by implication saying
that you don't have it
so you're also by saying that you are
there's a reverse side to your statement
I want and on the reverse side of the
statement I want that is the statement I
don't have
and I need
similar things please give me if you you
pray to
maybe God maybe you pray to Jesus maybe
you pray to Buddha they do that in
Buddhist countries maybe you pray to a
saint or whatever it is or you pray to
the universe and say please the universe
please give me this please give me that
that also doesn't work very well if it
works
it could be accidentally who knows but
usually that greatly diminishes your
power of manifestation because instead
the minister manifestation practice
arises out of a state of lack or
neediness so there's no powerful
manifestation there
The Secret of manifestation is expressed
in one simple statement by Jesus and
that encapsulates all the books
that have been written on manifestation
and will ever be written on
manifestationist was one simple sentence
it says when you pray for something
believe that you
that it has been given or that you
already have it and then you will
receive it
so the important thing is he doesn't say
believe that you will receive it
says believe that you have received it
so there the secret is hiding in that
statement believe that you have received
it rule number five is Manifest your
vision with Bruce Lipton one of the
things that really upset me for a long
time was the fact that I had great ideas
and intentions and I wanted to manifest
them and I thought this is how it's
going to manifest and so I had all these
visions of how things were going to
unfold and then I'd started processing
it wouldn't unfold and then it would
irritate me because it's like I've got
to make it work I gotta make it work uh
ultimately I started to recognize when
things didn't work it was possibly
because there were better ways to do it
and I wasn't conscious of it and so what
I started to learn over a period of time
was simply this there's an old saying
there's a means to an end and the idea
well the end is your destination
and of course the means are how you're
going to get to that destination well of
course all of us sit down and say yeah
this is what I want and then we start to
figure out well this is what I'll do to
get to those ends I'll get to this and
I'll get to this to get to the end
what I started to realize at some point
was maybe my awareness of how to get to
the end wasn't exactly accurate and it
turns out many of the times when things
didn't work and I was like so upset it
didn't work but it turned out oh there
was a better way to get there and I
didn't even know it so the universe was
really facilitating me and I wasn't
paying attention I was getting angry at
the universe because like it's not
working in a way I want it to work
and then I started to realize some point
was my God maybe the universe has a
better solution than the one I was even
thinking of myself so I really learned
over a period of time it's very critical
insight to help me get to where I am is
to focus on them on the end what is it I
really want put that Focus together and
it's very critical it's very interesting
because a lot of people have well I
would like this and it's a broad General
category and then at some point it's
like well it's not specific enough you
have to actually say what it is you want
I'll always remember I was uh looking
for a special shirt to go to a Pink
Floyd concert and and I just all of a
sudden visualize oh it'd be neat to have
a Russian shirt you know with a collar
that goes across here and a couple of
buttons down and I thought oh yeah that
would be really great that would be cool
shirt and then I stopped and I was
thinking where the heck do you get a
shirt like that I have no idea in the
world but I thought that would be pretty
good so I figured I still got to get
something so I drive off to a mall up
near San Francisco and I walk into the
mall and there's a first men's store
over there and I go let's start looking
I have no idea and I walked in and of
course there's this big circular rack of
sale clothes and I thought what the hell
it's only a Pink Floyd concert one night
let's see what's in there and I started
going through the wreck and lo and
behold oh my God a Russian shirt right
in the middle of everything and it was
like the shock of oh my God this is a
Russian shirt right here
the enforce the unfortunate part of it
was I had the picture of a Russian chart
I said cool
I never said what the color was or
anything else I just had Russian shirt
and there was a Russian shirt color gray
no color at all why I didn't put in the
concept of color and Universal well just
give it to him in Gray and it was one of
those things like oh be conscious of
what you're asking for because the the
more detail you put in
the more the universe can manifest a
resolution if you leave a lot of blanks
in what you want then all of a sudden
it's like well it's random whatever
fills in the blank because you never
said what you wanted you can have an
idea what you want and that's important
but the most important part of that just
having an idea is not just have a broad
idea I want X and I go no no what
exactly do you want why
go back to the principles of Science and
the principles of science reveal
something very important that principle
of science is this Consciousness is
creating our life experiences I go well
that sounds new agey I go no this is not
new Agee this is the primary principle
of quantum physics we are creators this
is a fact in fact uh quantum physics has
that but now let me add one other fact
epigenetics says the same thing because
epigenetics says your Consciousness is
controlling your behavior and your genes
and so it's time to stop for a second
and recognize where is your
Consciousness what are you thinking
about and the idea is start thinking all
those very positive thoughts but don't
try and tell the universe how it's going
to manifest okay you think of the
picture
let the universe get you there
and that's the most important lesson
I've learned I'm not telling the
universe how I'm going to get there I'm
just saying universe is where I want to
go
and then the universe will take care of
it it's so powerful it's so wonderful
and I never believed in it for the first
40 50 years of my life but I can tell
you now the life that I'm manifesting
today is a consequence of just what I
said focus on the end don't tell the
universe the means to get there rule
number six is practice karma yoga with
Michael Singer Karma Yoga is about
everything else
that's why Karma Yoga is the deepest
yoga it's not about your relationship
with your body with your heart with your
mind or even with your higher bodies
it's about your relationship with the
rest of the world with the rest of
what's unfolding in front of you how do
I interact with the reality of life that
keeps manifesting before me that is the
topic of Karma Yoga and it's often
considered the deepest yoga because it
is so expansive in one's life in fact
one of the deepest spiritual scriptures
in yoga the bhagavad-gita is considered
A Treatise on Karma Yoga
so what is karma yoga what is our
relationship with the world around us
in order to understand that to begin to
truly understand that you have to
understand two things one who are you
who's in there looking out what is the
nature of your being that has a
relationship with the world around you
and the second is what is the nature of
the world outside of you
first is actually quite simple
you are the one who's in there looking
out
this is what the essence of witness
Consciousness and Krishna murder used to
talk about objective observation
you are the indwelling being who looks
out through your eyes hears through your
ears you are the one who knows you have
a body you are the one that was in there
when you were six years old and when you
looked in the mirror you saw a
six-year-old's body now you see whatever
age you are and it will continue on you
are the Consciousness the awareness of
being you see the emotions that are
coming up from your heart you see the
thoughts that are created in your mind
and ultimately you experience great love
and sometimes Bliss as you get deeper
within yourself it's all the same you
there's just one of you there that's you
well what is the nature or the reality
of the world outside of you that is one
of the most fascinating and beautiful
topics
if you turn to science they will tell
you that 13.8 billion years ago there
was this big bang and subsequent to that
there were these thick gases of hydrogen
and helium
that fused together based on gravity and
built the universe as you know it
a wise person realizes that every single
moment of their life
what is unfolding in front of them is
the result of 13.8 billion years of the
universe unfolding and evolving until it
finally landed at their doorstep and
presented the moment that's in front of
them
to them so the world outside of you is
not of your own making
the world outside of you belongs to
science belongs to God it belongs to
Evolution it belongs to cause and effect
it is indeed the moment in front of you
took 13.8 billion years to get there you
can't call it your own you didn't make
it you weren't even here
the other way to know that the world
outside of you has absolutely nothing to
do with you it belongs to itself is to
realize that the moment in front of you
is no different than the moment to your
left or the moment to your right or the
moment behind you or the moment anywhere
else in the universe the universe is
expressing itself
everywhere you're just seeing one
particular moment one particular point
you can't say that because it's the part
that you see there's something special
about it it's just the part that you see
so a wise person comes to the point of
realizing that they are inside looking
out what is outside is the result of
creation it is not theirs it doesn't
belong to them it is just passing by and
they just happen to be seeing that
moment so karma yoga raises the Deep
question what then is my relationship to
the world that's unfolding in front of
me if it doesn't belong to me and it
doesn't again let's spend one more
moment with that if I picked you up out
of the moment you're in and dropped you
onto a street in Paris
then that would be the moment you see
obviously that moment was there before
you got there and if I take you away the
moment will be there after you leave it
has absolutely nothing to do with you
eventually a wise person realizes that
it's true of every moment if I walk in a
restaurant
that restaurant existed before I got
there it was going on the people were
there conversations were going on music
was going on whatever food was going on
I then step in I'm just seeing a moment
that already exists when I step out the
moment will keep going on it doesn't
belong to me it belongs to itself
belongs to science belongs to God
it's such a beautiful thing to see that
the world outside of you exists
independent of you you are experiencing
one particular moment of it and rule
number seven the last one before some
very special bonus Clips is become a
super attractor with Gabby Bernstein
this experience of having a Divine
connection to the universe and receiving
guidance and receiving messages and
receiving wisdom and moving in that way
and feeling directed and guided and
certain no matter what even when things
aren't working out for you you trust
that you are in the right direction
you're on the right path because you
have a certainty and a knowing that the
Universe has your back
that's what it means to be a super
attractor
and a lot of people you know I've been
doing all these
all these can I sit down for an
interview somebody's like
one by saying it means that you're
committed to feeling good
and the next question they asked me is
why did you write this book
and I say
because I wanted to feel good
and it felt so good to write this book I
wrote this book while I was pregnant
with my son
and I was birthing this human and this
book at the same time it was epic and I
just had this amazing experience and
this momentum and this energy and I know
that you can feel it who's reading the
book who's got the book
somebody even wrote to me on Instagram
they were like I can feel like I'm
surrounded by your womb there's one big
way that we block our manifesting power
particularly those of us in these
spiritual rooms and this is what I call
the manic manifester
and you're going to know right away if
this is you this is the person who is
like oh my God Gabby I'm reading all the
books and like doing all the meditations
and I'm like mantras mantras mantras and
I'm like feeling really good but like I
like just I'm just not attracting
what I want
do you know who you are
I can only see the front row but there
were some honest people here yes okay
good
so that manic energy like is that sexy
like no
absolutely not it's not sexy it's not
it's not drawing you towards it it's
deflecting you
so it's the same way we're deflecting
the the love and the support of the
universe when we're in that manic state
of having to make it happen and forcing
it to happen and trying to control the
circumstances that's that manic state
that keeps us stuck
would you speak about the
neurophysiology of forgiveness
sure
think about
Frozen circuits
Frozen circuits or hardwired circuits
the more profound the insult
to the person
that is connected to a strong emotion
the more the brain freezes circuitry
the more we think about the experience
the more we fire and wire the circuits
in our brain yes or no
and the more we remember the event the
more we produce the emotions that are
associated with it and we're
conditioning the brain and body further
into the past yes or no and you keep
doing it enough times it's no longer
conscious that you're holding a grudge
it's no longer conscious
that you're stuck
it's now you're seeing everybody through
the lens of that experience and
everybody's a betrayer
everybody can't be trusted everybody is
that same person you're you're
overlaying
the memory of re of your experience into
reality you're not seeing it the way it
is you're seeing that person wearing the
mask of the last person that's the lens
that we're perceiving reality are you
with me still
and so then anything in your life that
becomes remotely close to it based on
your limited perception triggers the
emotion in the network and you're back
in your past and you're acting like you
were when it happened are you with me
still
and so then the person says I'm not that
person and you say oh no I know I just
had this event in my past and I'm sorry
and then it's excusable but then here it
happens again
and there's nothing wrong with this
we all do it it's just how do we
overcome it
so then
you're sitting and doing the work
and you're you're moving energy up those
centers you're releasing the life force
into your brain
you are blessing those centers and
taking a scoop and moving it all the way
up and releasing it all the way up into
the field you're opening the channel
you're unfolding is nobody no one no
thing nowhere and no time and the
identity and the personality is gone
which energy is going to move Scott to
it's going to follow the path
you're opening your heart once it gets
to your heart it's going to make its way
all the way up and when you feel love
and compassion
when you feel true true kindness and
care it's hard to hold the grudge
are you with me still yes so then from a
quantum physics point of view
you have that person always in the back
of your mind right you have the event
and the memory rolling around back there
because the very thing that you don't
want to have happen you're already
preparing for emotionally
are you with me still yeah so then from
a Quantum perspective you are actually
as a creator of reality holding yourself
hostage because of that person
and you were holding them hostage
because of that experience and you have
an energetic Bond that's connecting you
to them
and you're sharing the same energy
and so then you're using each other to
reaffirm whatever that energetic
agreement is
are you with me still
so then
when you forgive someone it's because
there's been a strong change in your
emotional state
because the emotion is what's keeping
you energetically bound to them or to
more than one person
and so then once you start lowering the
volume to that emotion and the body
starts liberating energy and you're
calling your energy back to you because
the lower the volume of the emotion the
less you're going to pay attention to
that person there comes a moment where
there's a snap there's a release the
energy is broken and once it's broken
now all of a sudden you free yourself
and you free them and this has happened
to me in my life that people show up 10
years later completely changed and so
humble and so asking for forgiveness
just because
they had transformed and and I let them
go
so then
forgiveness
from a Quantum perspective in a
neurophysiological perspective is just
taking your attention off them
it's all it is and when you start
getting happy with yourself
and you start feeling those elevated
emotions because you're striving for
that you wouldn't trade this for The
Grudge you were holding because this
feels too good are you with me still no
once that heart opens up
and you start having energy in the
center and it's releasing 1300 to 1400
different chemicals that begin to
restore and regenerate the body the
bodies start getting a lift of energy
once it makes it's here now you're going
to see that track sending in energy to
the brain the heart acts as an amplifier
to boost the brain are you with me still
so then once the Energy starts making
its way into the brain once the heart
starts to open we've measured this with
our students they have oxytocin levels
rise
once you start feeling oxytocin when you
feel more love then you feel The Grudge
so then you think
why would I want to give this up for
that person
that's called forgiveness you don't have
to try to do it
it just is a side effect of your
personal transformation and oxytocin
then
when it's released rushes right into the
amygdala the survival center of the
brain and the research is outstanding
and the first thing it does is it fits
in the same receptor sites as fear and
it lowers the volume to fear and anxiety
it shuts the lights out for aggression
and anger and hostility and it cools the
circuits off for suffering and pain and
the only thing you can feel is a love
for life and that's when you're free now
the practice of forgiveness
manner to matter you can do it but it
takes a long time and a lot of work and
then you forgive and then you're like I
don't want to forgive him yet
halfway forgiven
and just never really authentic
forgiveness do you understand
and you know there was a woman that came
to our work
and
she was raped by four men
and when she was a teenager
and it was abusive
and she had severe severe night terrors
severe
anxiety and panic attacks she had cyclic
mood problems she had been to every
single doctor every single healer every
single alternative practitioner nothing
changed it
came to our event in
in Tacoma Washington
and she hit that point where she became
everybody everyone everything everywhere
every time every place she became the
Oneness
and and that frequency had a message for
her and it said and she was an
incredible Bliss when this happened
I sent four Angels disguised as rapists
for this moment
and that was the end of her tariffs
that was the end of her night she
couldn't have a relationship she
couldn't she could not live with anybody
she was she was isolated
one moment the Divine stepped in
and gave her the signal that was
carrying a very specific message and she
got the download not just that
not just the thought
she got the energy move right through
her body and she saw the whole thing
and that moment
is what she was waiting for that's what
the soul was waiting for now she's
healed she's healthy she's happy and
she's on with a new life she's born
again my mother would love this she's
born again in the same life reborn in
the same way didn't pass to a birth
canal for it she just was born again in
the same life she got a new lease in one
instant that energy was carrying a
message and it made its way all the way
into the body and the Bliss and the joy
and the Gratitude and the love that she
felt
and the message that was carried would
made total sense to her
she's free one instant to me that's true
forgiveness
that's the Divine having its way with
you you get your ass kicked along the
way things go sideways things go wrong
people let you down Partners don't work
out money falls out all these things
happen but I want you to reframe it in
your mind the success auditor success
tax auditor is looking looking and going
okay let's put another obstacle in front
of Wendy's way let's see if she can get
through that oh she saw the obstacle
turn around went back I don't think
she's going to be the one that reaches
her full potential but she could just
live life like everybody else and she'll
be okay let's see about liberio let's
see what's up Liberia let's throw some
crap in front of him let's throw some
fears in front of him let's throw a
massive obstacle wow
he fought it he was a little sad it was
a little tough a little stressful a
couple sleepless nights but he's still
going okay check that box let's wait
about three months and throw some more
in his way and that's what I believe
success taxes I think we have to go
through the trials and tribulates we
have to build the grit we have to build
the wisdom
or else we don't deserve it I teach my
daughter she's killing it in softball I
said you win when no one else is
watching you have to pay your success
tax by practicing all the time when no
one's cheering no one's excited no one's
doing it over the summer she's down here
in my office pitching because she's
paying her success tax but guess what in
the fall when she plays she's gonna kill
it when she comes out and all her
friends can be like oh my God
everybody's admiring you you got the
game ball I wish I could do that you
wish you could do it pay success tax
if you're not willing to pay it get out
of the freaking game don't think it is
listen everybody wants to be on stage in
front of 50 000 people jamming and
singing with everybody going crazy in
the crowd singing their name but you
know what everybody's not willing to do
is play in their room until their
fingers bleed to pack up an old van and
drive around to Gig to Gig when two
people show up most people aren't
willing to do that everybody looks at
the Beatles on how amazing they were
right do you know the Beatles paid
played like 10 000 different uh time
over over the years they played almost
every night like six nights a week
sometimes two gigs a night for years and
years and years never being noticed
sometimes one person in the audience
they paid their success tax and then all
of a sudden they were an overnight
sensation they weren't an overnight
sensation so think of it that way frame
it as success tax is part of the journey
and if you could say I'm not saying you
need to like the crap
I'm not saying you have to like the
journey not saying you have to like when
somebody screws you over the deal goes
sideways but what if you go wow if I get
through this I get another check box
from the success tax auditor you start
looking at life that way things change
and you realize you're here
because you're learning those skills to
get through them easier and quicker most
of the world most of the world sees a
wall and they turn around and go back
they're not deserving of the success you
are the type that will pound through it
get under it get around it climb over it
or blow it up with dynamite and that's
who wins the game so with that said
let's take it a step further
because I can talk about this until I'm
blue and like I could talk about this
every moment of every day when it comes
to my business because I've crushed it
in my business those fears that I had of
being a broke kid I didn't I didn't have
the right education I didn't go to
college I didn't have money I didn't
come from the right Town my parents both
worked to make you know probably 35
Grand combined separately and we always
stressed about money and I lived in a
bathroom with my dad I lived in a
trailer park with my mom until we got
evicted I mean crazy stuff right in
business I overcame all those fears I
failed miserably Winston Churchill said
the definition of success is going from
failure to failure without losing your
enthusiasm well I I did that before I
ever read that quote when I kept going I
paid my success tax I failed miserably
and I made it and in business I can make
those decisions I can I can fail
miserably I can lose millions of dollars
on a deal and I could be over in a day I
could I could have faith in someone I'm
working with and they let me down and it
hurts and I'm over in a day I can
rebound fast learn from it and go I have
trained my body I've trained my my my
insides I've trained my physiology I've
trained my words I've trained my
subconscious that we are freaking
Unstoppable nothing as a combined body
and unit nothing can stop us when you
have a goal in your head it's not even a
goal it's a fantasy it's a dream when
you have a book like this you can call
it your goal book and you write out your
goals and you go through I'm just about
to take you through bit by bit stage by
stage you go back to that but you can
look at it you can touch it you can just
make it real so remember if you do not
write out your goals as a plan and write
out how to accomplish them you didn't
have a goal you have a wish you have a
dream you have a Daydream if you want to
go get a pen get a nice little book like
this you can do it on your phone too you
can make a document in your computer
and be prepared to make your goals real
so let's start now get your book pause
this if you need to go and find one
create one and I want you to pick a goal
and do not even start with I want to
lose five pounds I want more money these
are what I call wishy washy girls no if
you can make your goals real you might
as well make them huge big enormous
phenomenal so if you say well I want
more money that's my rug oh hang on a
minute
hey I got ten dollars here there you go
you go well that's not my goal but you
said I want more money and I learned
this when I used to work with women who
were infertile that come and go you know
I just want to be pregnant I want to be
pregnant so bad if I was just pregnant I
go well as I look at your notes you've
been pregnant six times I know I keep
miscarrying
so being pregnant is not your goal is it
what
isn't your goal to carry to full term a
healthy robust bouncing baby to deliver
a perfect baby to be a great man yeah
that's my goal why don't you say that
because you can be pregnant lots of
times and never have a baby or you can
say my goal is to have a perfect baby
how about this my goal is to get lots of
attention for what a nervous twitch
explosive gas that will give you
attention but that's not what you want
is it nobody wants exclusive gas
so let's start with a big goal pause if
you need to
take some time open your book
and write out a big goal now you can
have a career goal and whatever I'm
going to have my own company create my
own business invent something you can
have a relationship goal my relationship
is wonderful we grow in loving and
respect each other and you can have a
health goal
but I want you to pick one only one not
three not five not ten one goal it can
be career it can be health
can be love pick one goal
and then I want you to decide why you
want that goal so much so the first
thing is I have a goal I want to have my
own business that's my goal and now
you're going to go to a next page and
write out why do you want to have your
own business so much and the more
reasoned you can write out why the more
likely
you will make that goal real so write
down why write down as many ways as you
kind of remember
you can come back any time to this and
think Oh I thought of another why and
another why so leave plenty of space
take your time and when you've done your
whys go to another page and write out
who will benefit from you achieving that
goal of course you will but who who will
benefit for instance if you have your
own business
you will employ people who will benefit
maybe your kids will go to private
school maybe your business will allow
you to help your partner have their
business
the more people who will benefit from
you achieving your goal the more reasons
you have
to achieve that goal so write out who
will benefit from you achieving a who
how and why will they benefit you're
going to buy your mama house put your
niece and nephew through private school
did you think of your mind as like the
genie in a bottle that says your wish is
my command
and I want you to understand that every
thought you think and every word you say
is a blueprint that your mind body and
psyche must make real so when you write
out your goals don't say I wish I could
be rich I long to be in a loving
relationship write it as if it's already
happening I am a millionaire I am in a
loving relation do you Michael that
doesn't make sense it does make sense
because your mind only works in the
present tense when you say next year
I'll have a bikini body it doesn't know
what next year is
and so you must write your words in the
present tense I am I always I have I do
this new page is about your discipline
how many hours a day you're going to
spend working on your goal
how often are you going to come back to
this book and look at it I want you to
write out I am
I always I have I do and I want you to
fill that in you see the best goal in
the world will not work if you don't
work and many people fail at this point
they write out a goal
my goal is to be a millionaire my goal
is to be famous my goal is to be wildly
in love and I think that's it it's not
it if you want to be madly in love right
are all the reasons why but then you
have got to put yourself in front of the
kind of person you want to share your
life with
if you want to start your own business
and you have a reason why you also need
to have the discipline to meet people
who will fund you sponsor you joint
venture with you so I want you to really
understand that the best goal will not
work if you don't work you can have the
start point
but you have to keep doing many of the
most successful people ever say well you
know I had a goal Luther Vandross had a
goal to be a rock star
and people said well you're an overnight
success you wouldn't I don't think so
you know I sang Jingles for KFC for 12
years that's a long night 12 years and
people said but Luther you're singing on
television that's cool you get paid a
lot of money for KFC he said yeah but
it's not my goal
and he stuck it out and many people have
got so close to success and had to keep
going and you have to keep going so
look at your Diesel and decide you will
give more to your goal give even more
work on it look at it write it out think
about it talk about it you must be
prepared to give so much to your goal in
fact you must be prepared to be
unstoppable in the pursuit of your goal
everything we as human beings have
created
on this planet
but essentially fast created in our
minds
all that you see which is human work on
this planet first
[Music]
found expression in the mind then it got
manifested in the outside world
[Music]
the wonderful things that we have done
on this planet
and the horrible things that we have
done on this planet both have come from
the human mind so if we are concerned as
to what we create in this world it's
extremely important that first of all we
learn to create the right things in our
mind how we keep our minds
if we do not have the power to keep our
minds the way we want it
what we create in the world is also
going to be very accidental and
haphazard
so learning to create our minds the way
we want is the basis of creating the
world the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day
a man took a walk he went for a long
walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired so he thought oh I'm tired I wish
I could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I'm well
rested but I'm feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him you need to understand
they have the services like that
[Music]
people don't ask questions food came and
he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink he thought about it and all of
them just appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's a
necessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghosts came
oh the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghost surrounded him and
started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghost
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization it in turn
organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body your mind your
emotion and the fundamental life
energies are organized in One Direction
once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible
levels of comfort and convenience to us
in the last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life
simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is how simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God he's the source
of creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all how
you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverberance is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive but what
you want see this line
that's called The Terror barrier yeah
jumping at you isn't it and on the other
side of the terror barrier is something
we call Freedom
and you know
very few people get through that Terror
barrier it's rather sad
freedom is available to everyone there
isn't anyone that cannot live the way
they want to live
see
why don't they
they don't know
and they don't even know they don't know
now I'm going to show you why people
experience buyer's remorse when they buy
something they really want then they
back away
where they go to move and they don't
they go to change jobs and they don't
they go to move to another city and they
don't why
fear causes them to stay where they are
there's the individual the X represents
the unknown
Factor the paradigm
now there's a power flowing into this
individual's mind and they can make
anything out of it they want remember we
said we have the ability to choose
what do they choose they choose thoughts
that are in harmony with the Paradigm
now here's an important point the
Paradigm controls the vibration of this
thing we call our body our body is a
molecular instrument that's really what
it is it's a massive molecules and a
very high speed of vibration
the vibration that the body's in on a
conscious level we call feeling
when a person says they feel this way or
they feel that way what they're really
doing is describing the vibration
they're in
now
they choose thoughts that harmonize with
the vibration they're in so they feel
comfortable they may not like the
results but they're comfortable
now let's move ahead let's take a look
here those people are getting X take
results and they don't like it
do you know what the problem with them
they're in bondage these people are
locked up
you know
Paradigm is like keeping a person in a
prison
only there's no locks on the door they
can open the prison to walk out into
Freedom anytime they want and they don't
they keep getting the same results over
and over and over again they're in
bondage
now let's go ahead here's the same
person
X-Type conditioning X-Type vibration the
power is flowing into them
and for some strange reason from Left
Field above boom in comes a y-type idea
what is the y-type idea the y-type idea
represents anything that you might want
to do that you're not doing
it might be moved to another city change
jobs sell the house buy the farm
whatever it may be
ask the little girl for the date ask the
guy to go to lunch
go make the sale
buy what you want
go where you want to go that's the why
idea but as long as the Y idea is just
in the conscious mind it's just going to
be an intellectual exercise it's never
going to happen
so how do we make it happen
well that's when
everything goes haywire here we are here
same person okay the power Flows In
and what do they do they got the y-type
idea now for some strange reason they
know that they've got to get emotionally
involved that they're going to act on
that idea they don't understand what's
going to happen but clearly understand
this your central nervous system is the
most complex electrical system in the
universe
the central nervous system
is mind-boggling yet would make the
electrical system in a supercomputer
look like a toy now the second you take
the idea from your intellect and impress
it upon the subject of mine that's when
all hell breaks loose because the body
moves in to an extra XY vibration it's
not in the X vibration not the one that
we're comfortable with may not like the
results but we're comfortable
no on a conscious level everything's
going crazy on a conscious level we
experience doubt that doubt turns into
an emotion called fear and that fear is
expressed through the body as anxiety
see that person is getting emotionally
involved to move ahead do you know what
happens they hit that Terror barrier and
they bounce off it and right back into
bondage
and they're so relieved to get back
there
they're back where they're comfortable
they've canceled the sale
they've decided not to move
they're going to stay in the job that
they don't like at least they're
comfortable
now that's not a very good way to live
and you know something that's something
everybody experiences if they're going
to grow you're going to hit that Terror
barrier see the terror barrier is going
Beyond where you're at going to a new
level I'm going to tell you something
when I set a goal
if if it doesn't scare and excite me at
the same time I know I'm going in the
wrong direction
now I also understand that my Paradigm
is going to try and get me to bounce
back to where I was it doesn't want me
to move ahead
I don't want to live there
I used to lived there for the first 26
years of my life and for the last 50
I've had a phenomenal life and it just
keeps getting better and I want you to
do the same thing understand what I've
just said I'm going to back this up
they got emotionally involved in the Y
idea that moved their body into a
different vibration on a conscious level
their experiencing some crazy stuff they
start to doubt their ability we'll never
be able to pay for it they experience
fear the fear expresses itself as
anxiety
and bang you bounce off that Terror
barrier and you're right back
oh I might not be earning much here but
I know what it is
I would love to move there but I'm
comfortable here I think I'll just stay
here these people are acting like they
have a contract to live forever and they
don't you know what to do say I'm going
to get rid of all that I understand it's
there but I don't want any part of it
and I'm going to go crashing right
through that Terror barrier
now does that get rid of the X energy no
that's energy
is still there you see but at least
you're over into Freedom you made the
move you did it and if you continue to
feed the right information into your
mind keep feeding that why idea keep
getting emotionally involved in the Y
idea you're there you're on the road
keep doing that you're going to find
that the Paradigm is going to change and
it'll just all go away
and you know you're living
in Freedom you're living where you want
to live
buyer's remorse
is when you cancel the sale
buyer's remorse is when you stop just
before you buy what you really want
before you go for the thing that's going
to change your life and you know it
it's not moving to the other city it's
not starting the business of your dreams
it's not stepping out and betting on
yourself
that's a terror barrier that's causing
that
and if you don't learn to go through the
terror barrier I'm going to tell you
something you're going to stay right
where you are
for the rest of your days
that's not a good place to be
what did Joseph Campbell say
so true
they gave you fear to enter holds the
treasure you seek I used to struggle a
lot with manifesting just the idea of it
I would watch videos on it and I didn't
understand what they were saying I
didn't I just didn't understand it uh
what was manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
cuddle of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
we'll choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth are
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected
now your brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with
and as soon as they came up with an idea
it's like oh you can't do that or I had
to have the perfect Plan before I would
ever take any kind of action on it and
you know just later realize that you can
never plan all the way out there's no
way you know if you wait to have the
perfect plan by the time you start
actually executing the plan is is dead
it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe the great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you show cut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then but when when you're
positive and optimistic and bold and
courageous and an idea comes to you
trust that that's the right idea for you
just trust it it's to write it and then
go do something about it where normally
what we do is we overthink and we over
plan we over prepare and then we lose
the momentum and then the next day and
the next week or the next month it's
gone it's over it's like oh I can't do
that no that was actually a great idea
for you and it's happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically but I just decide to listen to
it and do something on it and it leads
to something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts on where it's going
and what you want to create or who you
want to reach out to what you want to do
like what what thought comes to mind
after you're moving around and having
some positive energy that's probably the
right thing for you and just test it out
by doing something about it and maybe
that's a business idea maybe that's an
email you need to send maybe that's a
friend you need to reach out to maybe
that's an act of kindness that you need
to do whatever the thing is that pops
into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things maybe I'm a skeptic I
don't know but in running those
experiments I I proved to myself that
yeah great ideas do flow through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it so
number one reticular activating system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car when you buy
your new car you see that car everywhere
and then number two is trust a good
ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that
a lot of the manifestation a lot of
Attraction people talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that is it's not just
the people who'd associate with it but
other people have had a lot of success
where you're talking about whatever
thing is that you want that it's that
it's already happened that it's not
going to happen in the future but that
it's already happened you know if your
goal is to speak on stage then you're
visualizing and you're telling yourself
I I am I am on stage I am speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
I am speaking uh 70 000 people you know
I am I am the author of a best-selling
book uh I am like whatever your goal is
and what I think the point of that is is
yes one to see yourself accomplishing
big things uh two to not have a be so
far away that it lets you off the hook
for taking action but I think most
importantly is for you to feel what it
feels like to be that and the more you
feel like it feels like to be that the
more it actually becomes true if your
goal is to speak on stage in front of 5
000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something that
I would tell other people you know like
oh yeah yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because I
I am that big
but to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
but but look I've got I've got a belly
or I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm
I am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
foreign
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 50
amazing rules from Joe dispenza check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there when you begin to
create from the field instead of from
matter the only way you can do that is
you have to learn how to take all of
your attention off your body and become
a nobody take all of your attention off
all the people in your life that you
give so much of your attention